David thank you for joining us let me
start with a bigger picture here I know
that the contract to have a Final Four
is through I believe 2025 is there a way
that if everybody got together that that
contract could be broken that we
eventually get from four to eight teams
before 2025 I mean contracts can
definitely be ripped up with if they're
obviously agreed upon on both sides and
you know it's interesting to have that
debate I like I like more personally
because I like the exclusivity of it I
like that every game counting and people
say well no that game against you know
Clemson and Syracuse didn't count well
if they if they lost another one it
would account and you know end of this
series end of the year you have Georgia
versus Auburn winner was in and
Wisconsin in allow state that Wisconsin
wins there and if I think wins
convincingly maybe there is and yet
Clemson and the ACC champion game versus
Miami so I kind of like the system out
is I don't think it'll change I think
once you get stuck in away I think they
have to see it out a little bit and they
want it to go for a little while before
they start messing with it I love the
BCS but I think Dan the reason this
question has validity is because 2012
with the catapult for the BCS and
changing it because it was what Alabama
versus LSU and the same conference this
year you got Georgia versus Alabama and
obviously some controversy and the way
Alabama got in and answered those
questions but it's always a good debate
every single year yeah I think the
Central Florida element is what we're
looking for that you get that Cinderella
team that we have in March Madness but
it feels like just like with the BCS all
the pressure that we put on the BCS to
say go from to you know a 1 title game
to get four teams in there everybody was
against this all of the coaches you know
everybody and then all of a sudden
everybody goes yeah yeah I can see a
four team playoff nobody's you know
ready for an 18 playoff and I do like
the four with the XX exclusivity but I
do think having if we get rid of
conference title games having Central
Florida in there or Ohio State gets
another chance or whoever it might be
you
see that that makes it more interesting
for the college football fan across the
country as opposed to locking in because
it's two SEC teams hey these are the
last two standing I have no problem with
it but I do think that you need almost a
moment like this to create a little bit
of chatter and maybe change here with
the current system I don't disagree and
one thing that one thing that is pretty
cool it's been pretty cool watches we've
already seen Ohio State by the table of
the four seats so we know that just
because if they're not worn in - like
they used to be in the BCS doesn't mean
you can't win a championship and the
Central Florida thing obviously beating
the hopper who beat obviously Georgia
and Alabama makes you it makes you think
that kind of stuff but here's the thing
I think that also helped our decision
making we have to find a way to do away
with the cupcake games and I don't want
to do away with those programs and I
want to find a way to financially still
support those guys and make sure that
they have programs but if the SEC and
ACC play each other you know in the at a
conference and then the SEC played the
pac-12 and the SEC played the big ten
and the ACC played all the different
conferences and then we all passed up
more against each other if I have a
better field who's good and who's not
and who's serving at the end of the year
whose resume you know dictates at the
end of the year more so than than
anybody else so I don't doubt that
there's ways that we could tweet this
and make it better I just fell one thing
after being in the meeting rooms dance
all these years I was sold on the BCS
till the cows come home and all of a
sudden that same guy came in there the
next year and told me that if we're did
a fourteen playoff great thing and I'm
like wow that's got to change quickly
so there's nothing to say that we can't
get to Aidan less and more footballing
bad but we've got to you have to find a
way to shorten the season a little bit -
for the kids David Pollock ESPN college
football analyst former first-round
draft pick Georgia Bulldog all right are
you are you rooting for Georgia to win
tonight of course your school you want
them to do well if you always no matter
what thank you I don't always pick them
because I want to have credibility with
my job but it's very important to me
that I call it out I see it as a Georgia
guy that
and seeing Kirby's more coming in now
and change the culture and it makes you
proud to be a part of the university if
you were to make you proud to see them
playing not because they're here because
of how they compete like you just watch
people on TV and you can see even if
you're not breaking down the tape like
you can see when you got some dinners
that are just dude and Jordan got some
dude that are physical that play the
right way so that it's a really really
fun and of course you always watch your
school to win and do well did Nick Saban
recruit you he did not even that's not
true yeah how does this get out of hand
for either one I think if there is a
blowout it feels like Alabama is that is
the one that could blow out Georgia I
agree with that and I grew that because
if you watched the last game the two
games Alabama came out with a purpose
with a mission they weren't scared and
they hit Clemson in the mouth repeatedly
over and over again and if you watch the
Rose Bowl I think Georgia came out a
little nervous and a little bit not to
lose and I think it was it was it was
different and they they can't if you do
that against Alabama to rap so I like
that you have some question mark of
whether Georgia Georgia will it's crazy
for the moment I also think that these
guys are super excited to be here and
that means substitute they got their
juice and adrenaline a lot more than
Alabama who they come immediateiy Danya
like he's been here three years in a row
I mean they're used to it they're there
they're kind of a the gold standard and
the motivation factor to them everybody
knows exactly that Alabama syndicated
because of favoritism I guarantee you
curry will remind them of that nod their
minds the mental games that go with it
have fun tonight and don't be afraid to
say something controversial David thank
you David David Pauling drafted by the
Bengals first-round draft pick and
obviously defensive end edge rusher oh
oh gee yeah he might have been an
original edge rusher ESPN college
football analyst for more Dan Patrick
show too
channel 239 on Direct TV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]